at the very beginning, we
discussed the story behind this
book. Was on his way to Hajj.
And as he was on his way to
Hajj, he decided to write about
the prophet and so he didn't
have any of his references with
him. He didn't have any of his
books with him which is curious
because he's quoted from memory
over three hundred books in
this book here From memory
verbatim. And he almost
mentioned close to the majority
of Muslim Ahmed, The biggest
book that we have of the
compilations of a prophet
and Muslim and the six books of
hadith discusses them in detail
that indicates and articulate
to us that this man was a gem
of human of of human thought.
And that he was extremely
gifted and we can come to the
conclusion that the of the
prophet was not only memorized
by him and believed deeply and
digested but it was it seems
that it flowed through his his
blood and in his veins and made
its way into his into his
bones.
So, he wrote this book from
memory. Now, if you read the
book, in an in order, you're
going to notice that he kind of
starts off on a particular path
and then, you can almost feel
he decided to go head and
mention other things and go
deeper into what he initially
started. Because the beginning
of the book really discusses
first of all the and it's it's
important and its authority and
he places many many
principles and fundamentals
that he iterates and reiterates
and bolsters with evidence,
right? very eloquently how we
should approach the the
authority of the sunnah,
etcetera and then he goes into
things regarding the prophet
that would be considered by the
scholars as meaning the names
of his animals, the names of
his the people that would make
a then for him the names of his
guards, the names of his wives,
the names of his children. He
goes into that. And he takes a
turn and starts to discuss the
pillars of Islam. So, we see
that the book flows in a in a
particular way. However, it's
not in exact order that you
would expect the book to be in,
right? So, you'll find between
between the chapter of Salah
and the chapters regarding
fasting. There's this big
intermission with regards to
opening the heart and issues of
the heart and so on and so
forth and he has that
throughout the book. Things
just come to his mind. He
writes it down. So, some
scholars have tried to take the
book and put it in order. What
I mean by order is place
everything where you would
expect it to be as
traditionally placed in the
books of Filk. So, it's easier
to find. But doing this makes
things a little bit too easy.
do I mean by that? It makes
Have we heard of Ibn Heban? Ibn
Heban is the most illustrious
student of Ibn Husema. And they
are imams of Hadith, Ibn
Huzaima Hazamusannaf, of Hadith
and Ibn Hibban has a Sahih.
Based on his particular his
particular views with regards
to authentication of narration.
Major, major scholars of
hadith, major scholars of of
ancient.
Wrote his book
and he purposely made it out of
order. Everything scattered all
over through the book. Anywhere
you'd expect to find what
you're looking for according to
traditional orders of books.
You won't find it there. Why
did he do that? He did it on
purpose. He did it for that
reason so that you would have
to read the whole book and that
you would have to look for it a
lot in order to find it. This
is of the ways that the
scholars used to teach their
students diligence and to teach
their students how to look for
things so that when you find
them, you will not forget them.
He did this on purpose. And
this is why most of the books
with that that have attempted
to put Zad al Mahad in in order
as it were. Have not been very
successful. Because if if
wrote this book as he wrote it
according to the flow of
thought that was going through
his mind at the time and things
are not where you'd expect them
to be. And that's actually a
good thing for a a good strong
student. Someone who is looking
to, looking to digest, and and
hopefully even memorize not
verbatim but memorized by
meaning the entirety of the
book. This book it it I can't
over emphasize how important
this book is in the Islamic
Library. I mean, basically, he
took the and the life of the
prophet with all of the
narrations that seem to be in
conflict with one another and
he harmonized them in a
beautiful way and he drew and
he drew many many conclusions
from the of the prophet it's an
stellar book and it should be
left as it is. My personal
opinion, I'm one of the I I am
very, very, as you probably all
guessed by now. I'm I'm very
into the traditional way of
studying. And the traditional
way of studying dictates
repetition, repetition, the
traditional way of studying
dictates, not reading a lot of
books, but perfect most
important books right? And
also, that a book should be
left the way the author wrote
it. But for example,
dictionaries. All of the
dictionaries that we have, that
you go and you find. Whether
it's a
almighty towards you know, even
even which is a compilation of
four dictionaries. This book
which is a a lexicon dictionary
of the Arabic language You will
be very very hard. It will be
hard and very difficult for you
to find this book the way it
was originally written. You
know why? Because the way that
the scholars of the Arabic
language wrote dictionaries is
they would start with the last
letter. And go on to the second
letter and then go on to the
first letter. So, the order of
the book is actually not
starting with the first letter
in English dictionaries. You
open it, you look for the first
letter of the word, then the
second, then the third, you
find your your word. It's not
how Arabic dictionaries were
written. Arabic scholars wrote
their books the opposite. They
start with the last letter. So,
if you want to find something
that's that if you want to find
a word, you look for its last
letter first. You go to that
chapter and then you work
backwards. There's a very
important reason why they did
that. And one of those reasons
is to make it easier for
poetry. When you are looking to
write poetry, you find all of
the rhymes and all of the
letters that have similarities
in all of the words that have
similarities all clustered
together. That's just one
reason. There's many reasons.
Because the Arabic language
works very differently than the
English language works. But
what happened We took all the
books. We entered the
information in the computers.
And then we had them
alphabetized based on western
Western Standard. So now all of
the dictionaries that we have
that are recently printed most
of them. I don't want to say
all but you're very hard
pressed to find Al Qamus al
Muhiat the way that the
originally wrote it. Gonna be
hard pressed to find out of the
way that it was originally
written and that honestly is is
is very troubling. It's
upsetting because this is not
the way that the scholar wrote
the book. It should be left
alone. Leave it as it is. If
you want to ride his coat
tails, then, do it in a
different way but if you take
the book itself, just leave it
as it is. He wrote it that way
for a reason. These are
scholars that have spent their
lives studying and they know
exactly how to teach. They know
how to write books. So, anyways
Traditionally, the the kind of
took a turn and decided to go
all out. It it would seem that
way. You get that feeling when
you're reading the book and so
he starts to go into the the
pillars of Islam. So, the first
two volumes really are are
about the pillars of Islam, the
five pillars of Islam.
Specifically, salah, fasting,
zakah, and then he goes into
Hajj and Hajj is a huge, huge,
huge part of Zad Al Maad. He
goes into extreme detail with
the issue of Hajj. Now, We've
discussed salah, we've
discussed how the prophet made
how he made we discussed how he
made salah. We discussed a lot
of the things with regards to
that. Now, we're then we
transitioned into an issue of
the heart, issues of the heart,
which have to do with the first
pillar of Islam, That is
Muhammad. He's discusses that
at the introduction and in
these intermittent chapters and
now, he's going to start to
discuss the issue of fasting.
the issue of fasting. So, the
first thing we're going to
speak about with regards to
fasting is
the importance and the effects
of fasting on the body. Now,
before we start with what said,
we're going to as usual, have
an introduction and that is,
what is fasting? What what
comprises fasting? What is it?
Well, the scholars have Filk.
They categorize things any any
war they categorize them into
usually four categories, okay?
Sometimes five. So, they will
have conditions, pillars,
obligations, and sunan. And
sometimes they add a fifth
which is things that are
permissible, right? After they
finish that, they will usually
discuss the things that
invalidate. What they just
mentioned. This is how the
books of Philcar traditionally
written. Which is very nice,
very very organized, okay? So,
before we start, let's take
first, what is the definition
of fasting? We're going to take
the word in its original Arabic
context and that is a som.
Solomon. Psalm. He al Masdar.
The root word is sown. What is
a Psalm? A Psalm in the Arabic
language is to refrain.
linguistically, what does it
mean? To refrain and this is
something that was brought up
once. I remember that, is it
permissible for a woman who is
having, who had just had a
child and she's having
postpartum bleeding. Can she
fast under these conditions?
What's the answer? No. Of
course not. As one of the
things that invalidates fast,
she's not obligated to fast
during this time. So, how is it
that Mariam Alaihi Salam after
giving birth to Isa Alaihi
Salam is instructed to say
man. I have, vowed, a song to a
Rahman. I vowed to be in a
state of soul. Say, how can she
fast while she's in postpartum
bleeding? This is not fasting
in the in the legislative
meaning. This is fasting in the
linguistic meaning. This is why
she's she follows this up and
says,
so I will not speak to anybody
Today, I will not speak. So,
she is refraining, Refraining
from Roet in this particular
context, refraining from
speaking. Right? So, this is
the essence of what fasting is.
A psalm. Fasting in the
linguistic sense, a psalm, a is
to refrain from doing
something. Now, what does it
mean in the legislation of
Islam? They have defined. The
scholars of have defined
fasting as
Bonjour.
They say that the definition of
fasting is to refrain from
things which break your fast
from the break of dawn until
sunset. With the intention of
doing so. This is what fasting
is and the legislation of
Islam. It's definition. Okay?
Now, as we said, breaking
fasting down into conditions,
pillars, obligations,
preferable things, Sunan. How
do we break it down in that
sense? Fasting is very easy. It
has, it has two pillars. Number
one, the first pillar is
intention. Intention, that you
have the intention to fast,
before you begin fasting. In
for obligatory fast. Any
obligatory fast. Whether it's
for Ramadan, whether it's for
days missed in Ramadan, whether
it's for
a vow, whether it is for
accidental manslaughter,
whatever there is in the Quran
that mentions or in the sunnah
where a person fast and it's an
obligatory fast. You have have
the intention to fast before
the break of dawn.
They say. You have to have the
fasting intention at night
before the break of dawn. Once
the break of dawn comes, that's
when you start fasting. If you
don't have the intention at
that point, then, your fasting
is not, cannot be valid because
there's a portion of that day
which you did not fast. Fasting
comes in a unit. Just for
example, if somebody got up and
said, you know, I'd to
pray Hafa Reka. I want to play,
I would just want to pray half
a Reka. So, I'm going to
recite, make stand up, and
that's it. Would this be valid?
No, of course not. It has to
come in units, right? If
you're, if you're not praying
which is one raka, you have to
pray them in two, at least, at
least in two. The same thing.
And this is a common mistake
people make. When they go for
Omar or Hajj, it's a, it's and
it's it's perfectly fine to
make circumbomulate the Kaaba
at any time. You don't have to
be in a haram to do that. Let's
say you go and you make and now
you're waiting because you're
doing and that's what most
people do when they go for for
Hajj. Usually they are doing
the type of Hajj which is which
means that you reach, you make
Omarah and then you come out of
Iran and then you go back into
Iran on the eighth of in
preparation for the day of
Arafah. between the time when
you reach and the time when
Hajj starts, you're in your
regular clothes. You're not in
a haram, you're just normal.
You have no no restrictions at
all. And you go to the Kaaba
and you pray. Can you make just
by itself? Yes. You can make
the left at any time. But the
left has to be done in units of
seven. You can't make three or
four and it's valid. Oh has to
be done in units of seven,
always. Just making salah.
It's always done in units of at
least two. So, when a person
makes and he begins his talaf,
he needs to make seven rounds.
If he wants that the left to
be, considered valid. Same
thing with fasting. If you fast
for half a day, and then you
break your fast. Is have you
achieved a a complete fast? No,
you've not achieved a complete
fast, right? So,
The definition of fasting is
refraining from the things
which break your fast which we
will discuss inshallah the
things that will break your
fast. Refraining from the
things which break your fast
from the break of dawn. Another
mistake made by a lot of
people. I know of or I've heard
of a doctor. a doctor, who
spent
us. Starting his fast at
sunrise. is this person's fast
valid or not? No, of course
not. Because fasting doesn't
start at sunrise. Fasting
starts at the break of dawn.
Because in Islamic law, the
break of dawn, marks the
beginning of the day. In
Islamic law, the break of dawn
is not part of the night time.
It's part of the, it's part of
the daytime. So, the daytime at
the break of dawn, not at the
rising of the sun. So,
You have to begin your fast at
the break of dawn. What is the
break of dawn? Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala says
Allah says in eat and drink
until you see the distinct
thread, white thread, distinct
from the black thread on the
horizon of, of mourning, of the
break of dawn. Refrain at that
point from anything that will
break your fast until the night
time. When is the night time?
The sunset. When this disc of
the sun is under the horizon,
that's it. It is no longer
daytime anymore in the
legislation of Islam. Now, it
has become night time. Right?
And this is why
is referred to also as the
first
referred to as the first and
that we traditionally know is
referred to as the second
because these are night time
prayers. Okay?
Is a daytime prayer. It's a it
starts at the break of dawn.
When the break of dawn becomes
apparent in the horizon, there
are two types of dawn. The
scholars refer to them as
there is the first appearance
of dawn which is referred to by
the scholars of as the false
dawn. And then there is the
second which is the true dawn.
Your fasting is to begin at the
true dawn. Just begins at
true dawn. What a what am I
speaking about? What does that
mean? The way that you can
tell, one of the ways that you
can tell, the false dawn from
the true dawn. When the sun
rises, and begins to come out,
we will have at first a burst
of light in the eastern horizon
where the sun is about to rise
from. You can observe it. It's
a burst of light and it looks
just dawn. And then it
will go away and it will be
night again. Subhan Allah. And
then we will have a second
burst of dawn. That's the
second one. The second burst of
light. That is the true dawn.
The false dawn is that first
burst of light. How can we tell
them apart? The false dawn
always is disconnected from the
horizon. So you'll see light
here and you'll see darkness
under it and you'll see the
horizon there. Am I making
sense? The true dawn is light
that is connected to the
horizon. That's the true dawn.
So, your fasting begins at true
dawn. And it ends when the disc
of the sun is completely below
the horizon. No matter how much
light there is, okay? no matter
how much light there is. No,
it's still daytime it looks
but we break our fast
because we are not worried with
the amount of light or the
dissipation of light, we are
worried with the disc of the
sun that it is, it has sunk
under the horizons no longer
visible from our aspect. At
this point, we break our fast.
So, the definition of fasting
is refraining from things that
will break your fast from the
break of true dawn until the
sun, the disc of the sun, sets
below the horizon with the
intention to do so. And I say
with the intention to do so and
let's take a moment and discuss
that. Some people think, not
some, a lot of people. They
think that intention is
something that is very
difficult to do. It's
strenuous, right? I have to say
a particular thing to make sure
my intention is correct. When I
go to make salah, I have to
stand. you know, and recite
some kind of thing that will
iterate my intentions. This is
all not something that the
prophet was ever reported to
have done. He or any of his
companions anywhere ever.
Intentions are where in the
heart. Right? If a person is
making or or sits in front of
the sits in front of the you
know in the place where you
make wudu sits there and turns
on the water and I stopped him
and said hang on a second. What
are you going to do right now?
Obviously what are they
going to say? I'm about to make
voodoo So, why then do you have
to say it? You don't have to
say anything, right? You
already have the intention. The
same thing. If a person stands
for salah and just before they
make, I say, hold on a second.
What are you going to do right
now? They're going to say I'm
going to make salah. The
intention was already made when
you left your house to come to
the masjid. If you didn't have
that intention, you would have
never made it to the masjid in
the first place. The place for
intentions is in the heart.
issue with saying your
intention is what if you say
something that you don't mean?
So, let's say for example, a
person stands for and he starts
his intention, whatever it is.
You know, when I was a kid, I
was taught a particular way to
say it. You know,
the
only thing that's left is the
phone number and address and
zip code. After after you say
all of this, what about if I'm
standing to make and I slip and
I say
but I'm standing for and I make
salah. Is my salah valid or
not? Yeah, it's valid.
According to all the scholars,
it's valid. So, if this
statement you make has no
bearing on the validity of the
prayer, why are you saying it?
Am I making sense? Does that
make sense? Right. So,
intentions are in the heart.
You don't have to say your
intention the night before. I
intend to fast tomorrow, the
first day of Ramadan. You don't
have to say that. What's meant
by intention is that you
intentionally are fasting. You
don't wake up and make a a
decision. you know what? I
might as well fast today and
make it Rama No, it can't work
that way. You have to. You have
to have your intention the
night before for obligatory
fasting, right? When the
scholars place emphasis on
intention, they're not placing
emphasis on what you say.
They're placing emphasis on you
what what you are intending to
do. So, when I say for example,
one of the conditions of prayer
is intention. I have to have
intention to pray, okay? What
does this mean? or one of
the conditions of is is
intention. Some scholars can
it's a a pillar Now, how does
this affect anything? Well,
let's say for example, somebody
becomes Muslim is new to Islam
or somebody doesn't know how to
make Udu. So, I say, come, let
me teach you how to make Udu,
right? So, we both go and we go
downstairs and we sit at the
place and I say, okay, you do
this and you do this and I I
don't have Urdu and then the
Adan is made. I just made I
went through all the motions
but I never had the of making
My intention was what? To
merely teach him how how to
make wudul. Do I have to redo
my waldu or not? Yes, I have to
redo my wudu because I did not
have intention of Udu. That's
what the scholars mean when
they're speaking about
intention. Same thing with the
for example, listen, bathing.
You have to have intention.
That this intention is I am I
am bathing to remove Janeb,
right? state of sexual
impurity. So, let's say you
know, in our in our time, in
our place, usually, most of us,
I don't know. myself, we,
when you wake up in the
morning, you take a shower. To
get ready for work or whatever
you're doing. Get ready for
your day. You just take a
shower and the shower is the
same shower you would take for
for Janeb. So, I forget that
I'm in a state of Genava. I get
up. I take a shower for my day.
I put on a clothes, everything.
I took complete shower but I
didn't have the intention that
this is for Geneva. Do I need
to retake that bath or not?
Yes, I have to retake it too.
Remove the Geneva. This is what
is meant by intention. What's
meant, it's not meant by
intention that a person has to
say, okay, in a way,
in a wait and await and none of
this is part of part of the
scholars intend, the the juris
of Islam when they're speaking
about intention being in
condition of prayer or
intention being a condition of
fasting or what have you. So,
you have the intention to fast
before the day starts, the day
starts at true break of dawn.
That's when the day starts. If
you don't have the intention at
that time, what happens is you
have not fasted a portion of
that day. Any comes as a unit
as we mentioned. So, what are
the pillars of fasting Very
simple. Fasting has two
pillars. Two, number one,
intention. We just discuss
that. Number two, refraining
from things that break your,
that break your fast. That's
it. Those are the pillars of
fasting. If you fulfill these
two pillars, then you fasted,
right? Those are the pillars of
fasting. Now, there are
obligations of fasting too.
Obligations of fasting is
general generally abstaining
from anything that is haram.
Because this will deplete your
fast. The real intention behind
fasting is not that you starve
your body of nutrients. The
real intention of fasting is
that you is that refrain from
that which is haram. This is
the real intention of fasting.
The prophet said
we were Rafat. He says true
fasting is not to merely
refrain from eating and
drinking. True fasting is to
refrain from that which is
necessary and that which is
haram. So, basically, wasting
time, just doing things that
are unnecessary, or doing
things that are outward,
outright haram. This, this is
the purpose of this is the real
purpose behind fasting.
Now, there are certain things
that will break your fast There
are certain things that will
break your fast. These things
that we need to refrain from in
order to maintain our fast.
What are they? We can put a
number on them. Number one,
eating or drinking anything on
purpose. Notice the statement
on purpose. Knowingly. eating
or drinking anything knowingly
on purpose. And when I say
eating or drinking anything,
the nose and the mouth are both
involved in that process.
Because the nose goes into the
throat. So, if a person were to
drip things, medicine, whatever
it is and it goes down into his
throat, this is considered part
of that. So, eating and
drinking on purpose. If you do
it, forgetfully, forgetting
that you're fasting, you're
fast is valid. Even if you eat
a five-course meal, seriously,
even if you sit down and eat
for two and a half hours, the
whole time you forgot your
fasting. You're so full you
can't move and then you
remember, I'm fasting. Is your
fast still valid or not? Yes.
The prophet said, men
he says, whoever is fasting and
eats or drinks something, and
forgets them he's fasting while
doing so, then he is to
complete his fast because it is
Allah who has fed him or gave
him something to drink. The
point here is that when you are
fasting, you have to have the
intention to break your
intention. If you do it
forgetfully, you still, your
fast is still valid. Let's take
an example. Let's say somebody
likes grapes, okay? And so they
go and buy a bunch of grapes
and they're walking, walking,
walking around, eating these
grapes, eating these grapes,
and they forgotten that they
are actually fasting at that
time. And then they reached the
last grape. and they remember
that they're fasting So, they
look at this last grape and
they say, well, you know, I've
already eaten the whole bag. I
might as well, you know, not
throw this one to waste and
they eat the last grape. Which
grape broke his fast? The last
one. That's the one that broke
his fast. All the other grapes,
the whole thing, the whole
bunch, didn't break his fast.
Okay? This this is the the
first thing that will break a
person's fast. The second thing
that will break a person's fast
intercourse, sexual
intercourse, and in the four
any kind of sexual ejaculation.
This will break a person's
fast. Because part of the crux
of fasting is to refrain from
those two things. Eating and
drinking and sexual pleasure.
So this will break a person's
fast as well. But if it is
unintentional, then it will not
break a person's fast. What
that mean? for example, if
a person falls asleep and has,
has a dream. This will not
break a person's fast. What
will break a person's fast is
intentional? Okay. The third
thing that will break a
person's fast is to
intentionally vomit To
intentionally, induce,
vomiting, throwing up. To make
yourself throw up. This will
break a person's fast. If you
throw up unintentionally, let's
say you open a box or open a
freezer or something. You smell
something horrid and you throw
up or you see something or you
or something comes to your
mind. You think about it and
you throw up. Will this break
your fast? No. What will break
your fast is intentionally
vomiting? Now, a person may
say, why would this be
something that would even come
to mind? Well, there are times
when a part of prophetic
medicine is that you make
yourself vomit sometimes. And
the prophet did this. As is in
What what does that mean? Let's
say a person eats something
that doesn't settle well with
their stomach. Or they eat
something that is they they
feel is is rotten or poisonous
or whatever. They will they
will obviously make themselves
vomit. A prophet did this. He
must have eaten something. It
was spoiled or whatever what
have you. And so he made
himself vomit. So if you make
yourself vomit then your
fasting is invalid for that
day. But if you vomit
unintentionally, your fasting
is, your fasting is intact,
okay? There are few other
things that we'll mention
inshallah. We've run out of
time. we will discuss these
things next week and then we'll
start to discuss some of the
benefits of fasting and some of
the issues that Ibn Rahim Allah
mentions that is enough for
tonight.